Hi, I’m Evan Carmichael.
Welcome to another edition of Ask Evan.
In today’s episode I’m going to answer a question
from one of my newsletter readers Tony
who runs a construction company
and he found as he was starting up
he ran a successful company
wanted to offer more services so he partnered up
and acquired a whole bunch of other businesses
so he could be a one-stop shop
but now is finding that it’s falling apart
and people aren’t paying their bills on time
and he’s losing money
and wanted some advice on how to, you know
fix the situation and get back on track.
So Tony thanks for the question
really sorry to hear about your situation.
It can be common for a lot of entrepreneurs
to try to grow too quickly or grow in too many areas
and then be faced with a cash crunch.
I think one of the most important rules in business
is you want to build it around your customer.
And it sounds like you were trying to do that
you had your construction company
wanted to bring on partners
and bring on other businesses
to provide more value to your customers
but I would rethink
all of the different services that you have
and see if, you know
maybe some of them are not revenue producing
or they’re not really adding a lot of value to your customers
especially for your cash crunch situation.
I’d look at your top customers
see what value they’re getting from you and you know
which services that you’re offering
that you may have to cut lose
and those are tough decisions
because that’s money loss
and employee jobs potentially as well
but you want to make sure that you’re able
to continue on as a business
and I’d try to build it again
go back to that mindset of building around your customers
and focus on only the services
that are really adding a lot of value
to your major clients.
So look at every business that you brought on
and see, “Do we really need to have
all of these businesses still as part of what we do?
And can we trim the areas
cut them out that are really
not adding a lot of value to the business.
Remember that to make money
you have to provide a lot of value
and the more value you provide
the more money you’re going to make, right.
So talk to your top clients
see maybe if there are still things
that you’re not doing that you could to do
help solve some of their problems
and that could be another path of additional revenue
coming into your business
help get your company up to the next level
and also provide, you know,
more value to your clients
they’re going to like you more
they’re going to give you bigger deals
they’re going to stay with you for longer
they’re going to refer more business to you.
So you want to tie your business around your customers
and really focus on their needs
their pains and cut everything else in the business
so you can get back to profitability.
Hopefully that helps.
If you guys like the video
please give it a thumbs-up below.
If you have some thoughts or if you a question as well
I’d love to hear it if you want to leave a comment under the video.
And stay tuned for the next episode.